this video of a twice divorced woman
explaining why none of the bad things in
her life are her fault let's watch that
again I stopping with after my divorce
people who Judge Me based off of my
choices oh you would never get a divorce
no matter what cool well I've had two be
well also stopped with the narrative
that something was wrong with me nothing
is wrong with me things happened to me
that made me the person that I was and
have the struggles that I had you can
fix that anything that you don't like
anything that is no longer serving you
change it
[Music]
change it go to therapy do the
journaling practice meditation do the
things that you need to do to be the
person you want to be go to therapy she
says if we can assume that she's taken
her own advice we see again how therapy
has not helped